ah Hollywood it's a town where the
streets are paved with gold and dreams
die every single day seriously where's
that Goonies sequel we were promised and
what the heck happened to inception too
but while plenty of sequels to mega hit
films have struggled and failed to claw
their way out of development hell few
follow-ups have endured more setbacks
than gladiator 2 a long-awaited
follow-up to one of Ridley Scott's most
popular movies Daddy a tattoo was
valiantly tried to battle its way into
theaters but every time it rises up the
film is beaten back down it's time to
grab your sword and helmet and finally
figure out what happened well Maximus is
dead
when gladiator hits theaters in 2000 the
sword and sandal epic wild critics it
currently holds an impressive score on
Rotten Tomatoes and it took home four
hundred and fifty seven million dollars
at the worldwide box office the movie
also fared well during awards season
taking home the Oscar for Best Picture
and nabbing the Best Actor prize for
Russell Crowe but the film pretty much
turned Crowe into an international
superstar and the nearly two decades
later people still shouts lines like
this naturally with such a massive hit
on their hands
DreamWorks was quick to start developing
a sequel there was just one major
Coliseum sized problem with the idea
Maximus Decimus Meridius the main
character of the movie is kinda you know
dead in the film's climactic moments the
evil Emperor Commodus played by Joaquin
Phoenix challenges Maximus to a
gladiator battle there's no universe
where wacky Phoenix beats Russell Crowe
in hand-to-hand combat so Commodus evens
the odds by secretly stabbing Maximus
before tossing him into the arena
luckily Maximus is fueled by revenge and
righteous anger fighting through the
pain
Maximus kills Commodus for the Emperor's
own weapon before drifting away into the
Wheatfield afterlife it was a killer
ending for a standalone film but it
certainly makes things tricky for a
sequel but hey Hollywood had gotten
around this kind of problem before right
prequel problems these days prequels are
all the rage with everything from Star
Wars to x-men and the Alien franchise
going back to move forward DreamWorks
was looking to do the same thing to get
Maximus back into the world of the
living when people started whispering
about a new radiator movie in 2001 the
word on the web was that the story would
take place years before the events of
the first film it was set to focus on
Maximus the early days in the Roman
military
showing the Spaniards rise from Mia
soldier to mighty general producer
Douglas wick declared talks were
underway to get the ball rolling saying
you don't finally do something like a
gladiator - unless you have a dazzling
story to tell the studio was reportedly
looking to pay Crowe as much as twenty
million dollars to head back into the
arena the studio lines up david friends
oniy one of the original movies writers
to put the scripts together but much
like a Roman mob Hollywood can be fickle
and the project never made it out of
development shifting to a sequel
sometime between 2001 and 2002
DreamWorks decided to put the brakes on
that gladiator prequel and shift their
focus to a sequel the first big change
involved David friends-only stepping
away from his typewriter to produce the
writing cake then went to John Logan
another one of the original gladiator
writers with a new guy putting words on
the page the story was suddenly set 15
years after the events of the original
film that same year producer walter
parks hinted the film might possibly
jump back and forth in time but it would
mainly tell the story of lucius the
royal son of Lucilla it would have
followed Lucius as the last heir of
Marcus Aurelius
as he sought out his true father who we
would have discovered would turn out to
be Maximus director Ridley Scott's
esteemed on board with the idea even
declaring that Logan's script was ready
to go at one point however the sequel
was going to be significantly different
from the first film when it came to
action as Scott explains he wasn't going
to touch gladiators again a potentially
controversial choice for a movie
tentatively called gladiator 2 instead
Scott was more interested in the
political arena and wanted to focus on
politics and Praetorians
rather than blood and guts Scott also
expected to start filming in 2005 vs.
2004 faded into memory
gladiator 2 was still stuck in the
cinematic mud but work continued and the
film eventually
morphed into one of the greatest movies
and never made Nick caves [ __ ]
if you've ever heard a Nick Cave song
then you know the Australian artist is
basically an old-timey prophet armed
with a guitar his songs are brutal
apocalyptic and a spiritual in an Old
Testament sort of way and you get that
same vibe watching the movies he's been
involved with over the years Cave has
composed music for films like hell or
high water and the assassination of
Jesse James by the Coward Robert Ford
he's also written scripts for movies
like lawless and the proposition with
that kind of cinematic mind it's not
surprising that Russell Crowe saw
potential in caves fire and brimstone
brain asking cave to write the
screenplay for gladiator - what is a bit
surprising is how absolutely insane the
script turned out to be cave didn't
disappoint when it came to figuring out
how to follow up Maximus his death the
project was titled [ __ ] and
would have opened in the afterlife with
the Maximus realizing he's dead
unfortunately there's nary a wheat field
in sight and his wife and child are
nowhere to be seen
eventually the gladiator comes face to
face with the dying gods that ik Rapid
deities make a deal with Maximus
promising to guide him to his family if
he'll kill a god who's gone rogue one
who's betrayed the Roman faith and now
professors belief in the one true God as
Maximus agrees to do their dirty work
he eventually winds up on earth several
years in the future after returning to
the real world he discovers little
Lucius has grown up to be a savage
soldier one with a bad habit of
violently murdering Christians Maximus
eventually takes a stand with the
persecuted Christians leading an army
against the Roman legions but after his
victory he's cursed to go through time
as an immortal fighting in countless
Wars and popping up in every conflict
from the Crusades to Vietnam if you
think that sounds wild we didn't even
mention the purgatory scene the
Colosseum filled with alligators or the
finale that takes place inside the
Pentagon yeah the one in Washington DC
cave describes the script as a
stone-cold masterpiece sure why not not
over yet it's been pretty quiet the past
decade but Ridley Scott still haven't
given up on gladiator in March of 2017
Scott said he does know how to bring him
back in
Fenster Maximus so and never give up
right Maximus wooden thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
you